another day another racist faux pas by a
Republican that you're just not allowed
to call out because if you notice their
racism you were playing the race card if
you believe that I feel sorry for you an
ex trump advisor went on Fox News and
called the black Democrat quote out of
his cotton-picking mind of course the
term cotton-picking refers to one in the
south of the u.s. in the late 1700s the
early 1800s black slaves picked cotton
lou dobbs years ago once had one of
these weird incidents if lou dobbs is
before your time i know we have some
younger viewers on the show he used to
be sort of a prominent CNN anchor who
hosted a quote money show and I think
he's now on Fox Business if that show
hasn't been cancelled here's Lou Dobbs
act almost accidentally using the term
ten years ago we're living with the
issue of race we've got to be able to
talk about it and I can guarantee you
this not a single one of these cotton
yeah I'm these just ridiculous
politicians should be the moderator on
the issue of race right when talking
about how great things are racially he
calls politicians referring in fact to
condi rice who happens to be black in
that segment cotton pickin just cringe
so cut to this weekend here is former
Trump advisor David bossy quote debating
or engaging in dialogue with a black
Democratic strategist named Joel Payne
and out-and-out says cotton-picking take
a look here final one you said that
about David David Michael Michael Hayden
posted a picture of Auschwitz liberal
Michael Hayden you're out of your
cotton-picking mind we're gonna leave it
right this is ridiculous
ed Henry panicking saying hey hey he
said you out of your mind very quickly
got out of control eventually David
bossy did apologize for his choice of
words tweeting quote during a heated
segment on Fox and Friends today I
should have chosen my words more
carefully and never used the offensive
phrase that I did I apologized to joel
pain
Fox News and its viewer so the apology
is fine most trumpets don't apologize so
even getting an apology is something but
the reality is that the problem isn't
just that he said it it's that as soon
as he's in disagreement with a black guy
he immediately either consciously or
subconsciously goes to cotton-picking
and the question is why and even wackier
is that the the conversation was about
civility in politics and whether it was
appropriate for Michael Hayden to tweet
a picture of Auschwitz as an analogy to
what's going on with the child
internment camps and as you see on the
screen behind me their own headline for
the thing was the left's racist rants
continue as the guy from the right calls
the black guy on the left out of his
cotton-picking mind could this have been
pat some kind of avant-garde performance
art is it possible that david bossy was
on ambien a time and the ambien maybe
got him to say this wacky thing there
are people defending him online
like imagine this being the hill that
you die on people online are defending
david bossy saying that he's a child of
the 70s and any child of the 70s has
cotton-picking as part of their lexicon
with no racial connotations and it just
comes out reflexively and if that's the
argument my question is why is it that
the incidents in media tend to be white
Republicans using the term
cotton-picking when talking to or about
black people is it another one of those
coincidences yeah and why didn't you
mention that in the apology I it's weird
because whenever I get angry I don't
become a racist I think it could have
been the ambien I do I don't
all of a sudden incorrectly use that
term yeah that's that's the other thing
that always comes up which is well you
apologize for the use but it's clearly
what you automatically go to when you
become frustrated with someone in this
case when you become frustrated with a
black guy who quite frankly was making
him look pretty stupid on Fox News